so this element has the symbol you
little you be which pronounce something
like an an banging and the idea was that
we had that in the world there two or
perhaps three research centers that are
trying to create new elements by banging
together the nuclei of atoms lighter
atoms so accelerating one atom so it
bangs into another and they fuse
together to give a heavier one now you
can imagine that there's intense
competition the center in Dubna in
Russia or in dumb start in Germany or
also in America the Lawrence Livermore
Lab all want to be first so there is a
great temptation to rush your results
and claim that you've discovered it
before the others and eventually it was
decided that this was leading to really
too much competition and so it was
decided that there should be provisional
names from the elements depending on
their no atomic number so they devised
the number from system of numbers from
one to nine which a mixture of Latin and
Greek names so that you don't have any
two numbers with the same letter in
English for example you have six and
seven which both begins with s so that
wouldn't do as a naming system so this
one has U which is 1 and B which is 2 so
it's 1 1 2 so it's element 112 and so in
principle you can now have a naming
scheme for elements up to 999 but
bearing in mind that we've barely got to
118 this is probably rather more naming
that is going to be needed but on the
other hand it now exists and so
arguments between these labs should be
settled once and for all